pas parler de d'emmanuel macron dont on
va probablement beaucoup parlé la
semaine prochaine puisqu'il va faire un
meeting un grand meeting on annonce
salle de la mutualité à paris
on annonce donc son départ prochain du
gouvernement est ce que vous le
souhaitez ce que vous appelez de vos
voeux le départ d'emmanuel lumière du
gouvernement oui ça le regarde
entièrement j'aime pas de conseils
donnés et je n'ai pas non plus de voeux
à émettre ce serait à mon avis quand
même logique et pris position sur cette
question notamment lors d'un voyage
d'emmanuel mention à londres sur le plan
institutionnel oui je pense qu'il ya une
difficulté quand on est ministre en
exercice de en même temps alimenté son
parti politique
en marge de ces déplacements
ministériels moi ça me pose un problème
d anthologie vous aviez saisi la haute
autorité pour la transparence dans la
vie publique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où en
est cette saisine j'ai reçu la réponse
cette semaine
alors qui est alors je vous la donne en
primeur qui est ça ne relève pas de
notre compétence ça relève de la
compétence de la commission nationale
des comptes de campagne je ne suis pas
d'accord je vais donc répondre à nouveau
à la haute autorité pourquoi je ne suis
pas d'accord
on a créé la haute autorité pour la
transparence des revenus publics
justement pour éviter ce genre de
situation moi je ne dis pas que mes même
accro comme et des inégalités il a le
droit d'avoir un parti de le financer
question je me pose une question de
nature déontologique la haute autorité
ne m'a pas répondu
dès qu'on pose une question difficile on
vous répond pas dans ce pays moi
j'entends est ce que la haute autorité
me répond donc je vais relancer à
nouveau la haute autorité